Tony wrote in Tony says hey David which
drugs do you think should be legalized
or decriminalized so number one it's
good that you're making the distinction
between legalized and decriminalized
because legalization and
decriminalization are very different
things and also it's important to
distinguish between trafficking and
personal use okay so let's go in order
all drug use and drug possession for
personal amounts should be
decriminalized period legalization
absolutely for marijuana and for other
drugs I'm open to discussion you look I
believe it's Denver that's testing
legalizing mushrooms as an example I
have less of a fixed opinion about the
legalization of some drugs
I've not seen good reasons to legalize
recreational cocaine or heroin for
example I'm very clear that possessing
cocaine or heroin for personal use
should not be a crime using cocaine or
heroin should not be a crime but the
recreational legalization of cocaine and
heroin I just I've not seen a good
argument for that and I'm willing to
have my mind change now this gets us to
a really important element of this
debate that a lot of people miss a lot
of people seem not to understand that
when you talk about legalization or
decriminalization of any drug you're not
talking about it being legal to be
trafficking in those drugs ten pounds of
marijuana or a kilo of coke or whatever
whether you decriminalize or legalize
that is likely still going to be
criminal and when you think about it
alcohol is legal recreational
e-cigarettes are legal recreationally it
is still against the law to traffic and
alcohol or cigarettes without doing it
you know on the record as a business in
the way that the the guidelines say that
you should you can have that debate and
I'm glad to have it but it's important
to understand and I think that there are
a lot of bad faith actors on the anti
decriminalization anti
legalization tends to be the political
right in the United States who either
are misunderstanding or they are
deliberately conflating the
decriminalization or legalization of the
trafficking of drugs versus legalization
and decriminalization of amounts for
personal use and these are very very
different conversations so my question
to you today is what is the strongest
argument for recreational legalization
of drugs like cocaine and heroin I am a
hundred and ten percent on board with
marijuana I would sooner make cigarettes
illegal then say that marijuana should
remain criminal for use and possession
but I have not seen a good case made for
why there should be recreationally legal
cocaine or heroin but if you've got a
good argument to make along those lines
by all means get in touch and then we
can talk about it